un autre visage de femme qui sort de
l'ombre
roxane miam shawn lizotte fait partie
des quatorze femmes qui ont porté
plainte en mai dernier au commissaire à
la déontologie policière
dans son cas pour abus de pouvoir c'est
un regret deux fois ici à val d'or le
même policier exim cria après une
démarche en ligne droite que gta regarde
j'ai jamais bu une bière de ma vie la
jeune métisse est déchiré mon parti
québécois qui est allochtone c'est pour
moi c'est elle étudie pour devenir
policière dans ma communauté
j'ai vécu beaucoup de violence
psychologique physique j'avais plus
confiance en moi mais j'ai toujours
voulu devenir policière parce que je
veux aider les gens
je veux devenir un modèle elle est
ébranlée comme plusieurs autochtones qui
se sont réunis en matinée au centre
d'amitié autochtone de val d'or je suis
perturbée comme père de famille je suis
dégoûté la famille de cindy rue porte à
une femme autochtone portées disparues
depuis plus d'un an a lancé ce message
au nouveau premier ministre
elle étonnée vos promesses de la fait
attendre de naked publique nationale la
suspension des huit policiers qui font
face à des allégations d'agression
sexuelle ou encore d'abus de pouvoir ne
satisfait pas entièrement les
communautés autochtones de l'abitibi
témiscamingue
ici on réclame davantage qu'on demande
au gouvernement qui est de mettre en
place une enquête gouvernementale mais
qui est particulière et propres au
contexte de val d'or qui permettrait de
créer un espace à l'intérieur duquel on
pourrait également voir des témoignages
mais qui amènerait à des pistes de
solution pour recréer rebâtir la
confiance
le maire de val d'orge quant à lui reste
prudent oui ils ont encore ma confiance
parce que c'est pas vrai que c'est tout
le monde qui est à mettre dans le même
panier
le commissaire à la déontologie
policière affirme que tous les dossiers
qui lui ont été soumis seront traitées
avec la rigueur nécessaire pour tenter
de rétablir la confiance
une femme la capitaine ginette séguin
vient d'être nommé à la tête du poste de
police de la sûreté du québec de val
d'or ici claude bouchard radio canada
val d'or